87 protesters were arrested last night  in East Louisville for gathering on the  lawn of Kentucky's Attorney General they  were demanding the charges be filed  against the Louisville police officers  involved in the shooting death of  Brianna Taylor authorities say some  demonstrators were charged with a felony  after refusing to leave Taylor was shot  and killed by police in her apartment  back in March and what her family calls  a botched drug raid attorneys say  nothing illegal was found in a 26 year  olds home  Anthony you'll recall police later  learned the suspect they were looking  for was arrested shortly before the raid  yeah but police say that in terms of  that what went down there that they  tried did they ask the people to leave  the property but they didn't and it was  then that they charged them with  criminal trespassing and intimidating a  participant in a legal process